[Music]
it's a goal guys welcome to the stream
if this your first time here thank you
for stopping by if you've bared with me
through all this thank you so much Oh
down B is the oh my goodness do when he
rolls okay
forward B is the but can you angle that
or I don't think so
up thro
[Music]
that's his neutral air right there
dude look at this stage though man
that's a pretty cool stage whoo not a
fan of its of his UPS man
it's like it only hits directly above
him
try it again
oh-oh-oh we just unlocked we just don't
like persona
[Music]
let's try it I want to try that up smash
it a little bit more see how if it hits
in front of them at all or if it's
literally just above oh okay
okay a little bit
that's his forward be down be is the I
think it to get you the persona faster
[Music]
four would be right there or forward uh
air neutral airs right there that little
law who that looks like a spike move
right there down here
[Music]
I was down smash right there
oh yeah haven't even used this uh just
as neutral special yet
Kirby straight-up gets a Glock Oh Samus
a Dark Samus team battle Kirby joins the
team but you can just hold down me like
hold down the button beep not down and
be
oh my goodness water recovery get out of
the way
all dude let's see his final smash
come on yes
let's go dude oh my goodness are you
kidding me that is awesome
no way okay just for pure aesthetics
that's final smash in the game not
talking in terms of like how good it is
I mean it wasn't that hard to hit but
wow I mean so true that looks like it's
right out of persona 5 man crazy
lipstick for the win let's go dude
Rocketeer seriously man that up B oh my
gosh I was so far under the stage so far
under woo now Samus joins my team I
think you can actually use it to grab
them too like that oh that could be
really interesting people are like
hanging out on a platform above you it
isn't something people would do often in
ultimate
see that's his back air gang Sam is
doing work or was that the I think that
was the assist Rafi this is gonna be so
annoying way too early to tell way too
early to tell
oh we have to play him in bracket
oh my gosh just it's worth it for the
music alone dude
persona music so good
it doesn't feel like it takes that long
to get the persona even when you are
going you're not using downbeat
really
[Music]
dang that's pretty powerful right there
when you have it for some of the guns
more powerful
dude this stage though man as long as
you have stage hazards off minded up
being a legal stage I don't know
I can't wait to see who is final boss'
classic let's find out
Oh
that looks pretty cool down there
with the persona
come on link help me what is he doing
give me a little systems here bullet oh
I need to be using that more whenever I
have the persona unlock
yeah that's pretty powerful there we go
let's go dude to 35% ain't nothing times
are tough for the Little Mac main sets
Rockets here giant stage and talks are
being legal fast tidy DPS character good
mobility no bus for our boy little man
Nintendo got a Nintendo
I'm surprised there weren't more changes
though honestly with the patch seems to
be pretty
failure what a failure
noomane I know way I'll never stop
mating samus I don't think I would ever
move away from Samus Master in and crazy
aunt okay no big surprises here how
insane would it be if they pulled a
persona boss though dude
[Music]
yeah that doesn't do much of anything
when they're not
[Music]
and you don't have your persona maybe
there's something I mean probably
possible there's something about it I
don't know
[Music]
oh come on
yay
[Music]
ya knew that was coming let's just use a
ticket
[Music]
almost got master
dude oh my goodness 63%
[Music]
okay I'm gonna die again doing nothing
duh Master Hand now
[Music]
oh come on
I'm actually trying to dodge now instead
of just like trying to tank everything
oh there we go
saying that does not do much to master
can their crazy hand at all
there we go